c'était en 2014 à paris des milliers de
personnes rassemblées pour célébrer les
50 ans de l'arche consécration de
l'oeuvre humanitaire d'un homme inspiré
ou heureusement été interdites la
normalité tout le monde doit tête paraît
essai c'est des gens différents et ils
sont libres son aventure humaniste
commence en 1964 en france dans un
village de picardie avec une idée
complètement folle il convainc les
autorités locales d'héberger chez lui
deux hommes handicapés intellectuels
pour leur permettre de vivre en société
en dehors des sinistres asile
psychiatrique de l'époque je sentais
qu'il se dise qu'il fallait que je fasse
un changement de vie radical pour le
fils du gouverneur général du canada
georges vanier jean vanier avait d'abord
été officier de la marine royale avant
d'enseigner la philosophie à
l'université à toronto malgré les
réticences de départ
l'arche grandi l'organisme compte plus
de 150 foyers sur les cinq continents
dont 26 au canada tout caire ap ap les
peaux il reçoit des prix prestigieux
dont le thème porteur à londres en 2015
décerné avant lui à mère teresa ou dalaï
lama et à des semaines tout mais son
entreprise est entachée par un scandale
un prêtre qui a participé à la fondation
de l'arche aurait abusé de plusieurs
femmes bouleversé jean vanier demande
pardon pour tout ce qu'il n'a pas fait
pour protéger ces personnes c'est de la
maladie a déjà remanié devant les
journalistes qui l'accompagnaient plus
tôt aujourd'hui le parc françois s'est
dit attristé de la mort de jean vanier
au canada dans le québec par thor il y
avait tous ces institutions hoon
enfermer des gars super et s'était
enfermé à vie
récemment jean vanier s'était confié à
notre collègue il se disait prêt à
passer à la prochaine étape et toujours
ce sentiment profond que je suis aimé de
dieu
donc ça ira pourquoi s'inquiéter
de toute façon on y va quand s'inquiète
quand sa kippa sylvain desjardins radio
canada montréal